six women who blew the whistle on
alleged sexual misconduct at an elite
Ivy League college are speaking out
publicly for the first time their
accusations last year led to the ouster
of three prominent professors in the
psychology and brain sciences department
at Dartmouth College a criminal
investigation is now underway in New
Hampshire the women spoke with Jericka
Duncan for a story you'll see only on
CBS this morning
tareka good morning good morning it's
almost like here we go again a few hours
ago the women filed a 70 million dollar
federal lawsuit accusing Dartmouth
officials of ignoring numerous
complaints going back more than a decade
they claim the school didn't protect
them from the professor's predatory
behavior which they say included groping
harassment and even worse both of you
all say you were raped by former
Dartmouth professors yeah I would say so
to hear me ask you that question what
goes through your mind I still can't
accept that that happened
twenty-seven-year-old básico Chauhan and
30 year old Christina Rapuano are
budding cognitive neuroscientists Xiao
Han is working on her PhD at Dartmouth
College
Rapuano received hers this year Rapuano
says while attending a conference in
California in 2015 she was raped by
William Kelly a professor who had taken
her under his wing essentially I have no
memory of this night I didn't even
remember waking up I remember how much
you had to drink I had thought that I
had just been drinking heavily
now I'm unsure what did he tell you
happen that we had sex and I had no
memory of it but I was very clear about
how I didn't want that to ever happen
again
Chao Han says she was raped last April I
have a strategy in the home of Paul
Whalen another star professor I tried to
get out of the situation as soon as
possible
it was only when he started reaching for
more intimate parts of my body that I
was on amber
was about the fact that this is not
something I wanted Kelly and Whelan
resigned this summer after Dartmouth
hired an outside investigator a third
professor Todd Heatherton retired
Dartmouth says the men did not receive
any severance payments in a federal
lawsuit filed this morning seven women
including Rapuano in chow han say
Dartmouth administrators knew about the
animal house culture in the department
since at least 2002 these professors
leer debt groped sexted intoxicated and
even raped female students according to
the class action complaint how many of
you all were either sexually assaulted
or sexually harassed by former Dartmouth
professors raise your hand all of you
anne-marie Brown Andrea Courtney Sasha
Britt ski and Marissa Evans are also
plaintiffs how many of you all felt
supported when you went to
administrators about what happened no
one these men had all of the power in
the department they controlled all their
resources opting out of the boys club
culture meant that you were cut off from
those resources I went to my first
academic conference in March 2017 I was
at a karaoke bar with a bunch of other
graduate students Todd Heatherton came
in extremely intoxicated he grabbed my
but didn't set me on his lap and now I
had been sexualized in front of a room
full of potential colleagues I felt
humiliated and I felt extremely angry I
had a conversation in my first year of
graduate school with Paul Whalen in
which he openly bragged about
retaliation did you feel like he was
threatening you I was confused at the
time but the line of course you you
don't bite the hand that feeds you was
burned into my memory for all of
graduate school and it remained a
constant threat I took every course that
beau Kelly offered in the department he
started to escalate all of those
inappropriate text messages and make it
more sexual I would blow it off the best
that I could but when I did I was taking
off of projects I would get comments
like your honors thesis just got a lot
harder a Dartmouth spokesman told CBS
this morning they'll
the women for bringing the misconduct
allegations to their attention last year
however we respectfully but strongly
disagree with the characterizations of
Dartmouth's actions in the complaint
it's really intimidating to come out as
a victim rather than a brain scientist
which is what we went to Dartmouth
stubbe sø you feel like you may take a
professional blow by speaking out yes
we've gotten a lot of professional
feedback to just put our heads down and
do science I lose sleep at night
thinking of like all of the discoveries
and science that haven't been made
because women were driven out through
his attorney taught Heatherton denied
ever having sex with students he did
admit he acted unprofessionally while
intoxicated for which she apologized our
attempts to reach Kelly and Whalen were
unsuccessful as I you know we were
talking about it while the story was
airing there's so much here and it
really comes down to the power these
were their academic advisors one
professor was responsible for bringing
in over 21 million dollars in grant
money to the unit to the College so they
felt this obligation according to them
to play this game in order to advance
they were doctors oh yeah they were
professors they were their mentors they
were I think I think the other important
thing to point out was that last sound
bite but when laying awake at night
thinking about all the scientific
discoveries that have not been made
because women were pushed out that that
is true in every field that harassment
happens everything reminds me of the
piece that you did in the military I
mean all the great visitors who wanted
to serve our country and they justify
fighter jets deal with the serve in
combat but I've been pushed out because
of systematic and pervasive harassment
yeah and the retaliation that followed
suit right very glad they're speaking up
yes thank you tarika